yes you up in the back
do you agree with abortion
do i agree with abortion i agree my view
is that government
should not
make the judgment therefore i have voted
for 15 years consistently
against limiting the right of a woman to
make a decision with her doctor whether
or not she should have an abortion and
on the other side i have also voted
against direct government funding of
abortion if you say government should
stay out
government should stay out
in my opinion
hey what's going on everybody we are
live on youtube on rumble and on blaze
tv do me a favor
subscribe wherever you're watching right
now
thank you all right uh that was joe
biden uh that was about uh gosh that's
almost 35 years ago or so at this point
and we wanted to start with that clip
this morning as the cold open because uh
joe biden used to sort of make some
sense he was always sort of politician-y
he was always sort of glib and all of
that stuff but it was interesting to
hear his thoughts on abortion way back
when that was when he was running for
president back in 1998 he actually had
to end his campaign early a lot of
people don't know this because he was
caught plagiarizing of course then he
became vice president and president a
couple decades after
that uh 1988 that was yeah uh really
just like what a time warp that these
people are still involved in anything at
this point it's nuts but the point is he
was making a little bit of sense related
to abortion and he sort of wanted to
respect privacy and that sort of thing
and ironically you know if you'd want
the government out of abortion well then
you'd sort of not want it to be
federally mandated across the state so
you'd think that joe biden of 1988 might
be sort of happy as to what happened a
couple days ago via the reversal of roe
v wade but here we are
i don't think i told you my name or the
title of the show i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report and i'm very happy to
be with you today and we got a jam
freaking packed show that is going to
leave you feeling enlightened and a
little more ready to fight the insanity
uh real quick guys uh before we get to
that on july 14th in miami i'm at the
miami improv and we just confirmed it
this morning
governor ron desantis press secretary
christina pusha is going to be joining
me on stage we're going to do this
differently than we've done any of the
other tour shows because this is just an
add-on show in my new hometown of miami
so this will be a live reuben report
episode we are going to write the entire
show that day and do it live with video
clips and all that and christina is an
absolutely
awesome advocate not only for the
governor uh but for florida and for
freedom and much more so i'm very
psyched to have her and who knows who
else might show up uh we shall see you
can get tickets at daverubin.com
events okay so yesterday i ended the
show by playing uh this little minute
and a half or two minute segment uh from
the audiobook of don't burn this book
where i laid out what my feelings on
abortion are and as you know i describe
myself as begrudgingly pro-choice i do
not deny that when the sperm meets the
egg that that is the genesis of life
there has to be a beginning and
basically that's the only place it could
be we could have all sorts of
discussions about a soul and the
evolution and biology of the gestational
period and by the way i'm going to get
into some of the science
on that in just a few minutes but really
where we're at at this point is that
half the country now seems to want to
burn the thing down and another half of
the country is sort of feeling good like
oh maybe a little bit of the power was
restored to the people but how do we
arbitrage those two positions how do we
get if there's any chance that this
union can hold how do we get all of
these people who are seemingly seeing
the world in totally different ways how
do we get some of them or at least the
bulk of them or a decent enough portion
of them
to agree that we're gonna be okay so i'm
gonna try to debunk a couple things here
today uh first off there's a lot of
people freaking out that suddenly the
supreme court is gonna come for
interracial marriage and gay marriage so
we're gonna try to debunk that uh we're
gonna also try to debunk some nonsense
related to these people who want eight
seven eight six seven eight month
abortions and somehow think that that is
not murder when it obviously is uh we're
gonna talk about a bunch of other things
related to science and biology and then
of course uh we'll get to the democrats
and media and
it has nothing to do with science
biology or anything sane
real quick guys you may want to strap on
a relief ban but i play some of those
clips a bit later
because you might get nauseous you know
were joe biden and the disastrous
democrats policies making you nauseous
did you know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
but there's a solution you've got to
check out relief band relief band's the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that's clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and much more how it works is relief
band stimulates a nerve in the wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea then it blocks the
signal your brain is sending to your
stomachs telling you that you're sick
it's like the name says it's
legitimately a band that you wear on
your wrist to give you relief from
nausea and anxiety and you change the
intensity depending on how you're
feeling to make it stronger or weaker
it's that simple the technology was
originally developed over 20 years ago
in hospitals to to relieve nausea from
patients but now through relief band
it's available to the masses plus it's
100 drug-free non-drowsium provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
and they just released their newest
model relief band sport the sport is
waterproof has an extended battery life
and can even attach to your apple or
android watch so if you're finally
taking this that summer trip or just
nauseous from everything going on in the
world i've got some good news right now
you can join over the hundred thousand
relief band users out there with an
exclusive offer just for reuben report
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
and use promo code ruben you'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and no
questions asked for a 30-day money-back
guarantee remember it's better to have a
relief ban and not need it than to not
have it at all so head on over to
reliefband.com and use my promo code
ruben for 20 off plus free shipping okay
so how
did we
get here how did we get to this place
where now the country seems even more
divided than we seemed say
ten days ago because that is what it
feels like right now remember ten days
ago we were divided over guns now we're
divided over abortion next week it'll be
something else two months before that it
was something else it's covered it's
injections it's economy it's always
something that's out there but the
abortion thing because it goes to such
depth of what humanity is all about the
way we view the world what our personal
philosophy is our religious views our
views of secularism and government it
really unearths almost everything
so some of you may know charlemagne the
god he's a huge radio host podcaster
and he is a democrat he is a liberal and
a democrat and i suppose a progressive
and he's interviewed kamala harris and a
whole bunch of the democrat politicians
but he's now squarely blaming a lot of
what's happened on the democrats
themselves as opposed to putting it at
the feet of the republicans which i
thought was sort of interesting
okay what we witnessed on friday is the
cowardice of the democratic party
catching up to them all right they know
what republicans have been planning for
decades republicans have never hidden
their agenda they have shown and told us
what play they are going to run and for
some reason democrats never craft a
defense to stop it all right i mean we
didn't just get here yesterday people
yes it's easy to point the finger at
donald trump mitch mcconnell and say
yeah they put three judges on the
supreme court that's true but i feel
like the cowardice and inaction from
democrats caused a lot of this i have a
million questions that people smarter
than me can answer
now the reason i wanted to play that
clip was it's interesting because i do
want to always listen to people on the
other side and hear what they're
thinking about issues when they think
something completely different than me
so obviously he he
i don't he loves abortion but he's
obviously not happy about roe being
overturned and he's blaming this on the
democrats because he's saying hey the
republicans said what they were going to
do the whole time now the issue is
although i disagree with him on on sort
of probably the fundamental reality of
what happened here i do believe in the
constitution and the fact that there is
no constitutional right to abortion as
was just decided um what i do agree with
him on is sort of the ineptitude and
stupidity of the democrats they have
pushed and pushed so far
that people who would not have cared
about this people who were really
willing to let rose sit there um
have decided that they didn't want to
let roe sit there because they kept
seeing the democrats move on everything
they kept seeing the move on the woke
stuff the gender stuff the critical race
theory stuff the abortion stuff meaning
have eight month abortions so this is
that sort of you give them an inch they
take a mile and i would say that the
perfect example of that is that cold
open that we just showed you of joe
biden in 1998 and you know what for the
clip purposes conor let's put that clip
in right here again okay let's do that
for the clip purposes when we do this a
little bit later uh
joe biden in 1998 sounding somewhat
measured understanding his own personal
beliefs versus government and all of
those things versus joe biden of today
where he basically is saying it is a
fundamental right they've taken away
fundamental rights they're coming after
women and all of this hysteria remember
again the only argument for voting for
joe biden as president was that he was
the firewall he was going to stop evil
fascist donald trump and he was the
firewall against crazy wokism and
ironically he's the one who has ushered
it in but the hysteria of course is not
just about the the politicians it also
is all of their friends in the media and
watch out people i'm about to show you a
clip from the view
don't we uh separation
and have thomas jefferson there and
alexander hamilton hello yeah uh do we
still have a separation of church and
state here is in the constitution yeah
it's a it's the first amendment
guarantee and we don't seem to have that
anything we're in a democracy right now
okay the level of stupidity there is so
off the charts first off sunny hostin
this has nothing to do with the first
amendment you can say whatever you want
they can get up there and say that we
live in a theocracy okay it's not true
but they can say it uh also
she's talking about the separation of
church and state there was no religious
argument made in any of the supreme
court justice's paperwork on this there
was no nothing that had to do with
religion it was explicitly what is in
the constitution which is basically a
secular document
the founders were believers all in their
own way and they went back and forth in
that and they talked about a moral
people and they talked about the
separation of church and state obviously
no one is being dictated to live a
certain way right nobody is being
told oh you must believe in christ you
must be a christian and must do this or
that all this is is a
give back it's a give back people like
the the buyback when they do gun
buybacks this is a give back of the
power to the states so this is a
decentralization of power what this is
unearthing within the progressives what
it's showing all of us
is that they just want
one power over us they want one ring to
rule us all basically and that's what
they're upset about so here you have joy
behar talking about the separation of
church and state while she's basically
spitting all over the separation of
powers the idea that we do have a
judiciary that decides what's legal and
a legislative branch that writes the
laws and an executive branch that
executes those laws right that is what
is a key uh facet of the constitution of
the rule of law that we have here by the
way the definition of a theocracy since
uh joy behar brought that up a system of
government in which priests rule in the
name of god or a god
does that sound like what's happened
here they literally said hey states can
you figure out what's going on with
abortion you make your decisions and you
know hopefully the people in your states
will vote a certain way and then if you
want no abortions or eight-month
abortions or 12-week abortions or
whatever go ahead and do that does this
sound like the priests are doing
something in the name of god is that
what this really sounds like it's
endless it's endless hysterical uh
hysterical lunacy i mean it's the only
way to put it but the new meme out there
also is that what they're coming for
next now that they've done this now that
they've given the right
of abortion to the states and of course
you're allowed to leave the state and
get an abortion still but now that
they've done that they're coming for
interracial marriage black people will
not marry white people and of course
they're coming for gay marriage too
here's whoopi goldberg
i want people to have the lives they
want but i don't want to force anybody i
don't want anybody coming in my house
telling me how to raise my daughter and
what she needs because they don't know
these and i and i appreciate everybody's
religion but i do not subscribe to your
religion i don't ask you to subscribe to
mine and you do not have the right based
on your religious beliefs
to tell me because what's next as
clarence thomas is signaling they would
like to get rid of contraception do you
understand sir no because you don't have
to use it but that's crazy they don't
have to use it
now contraception is on the menu gay
marriage is not a whole probably going
to be because we weren't affirmative we
were not in the constitution either we
were not even people
nothing is present way more well you
better hope that they don't come for you
clarence and say you should not be
married to your wife who happens to be
white
because they will move back and you
better hope that nobody says you know
well you're not in the constitution
you're back to be in a quarterback 15.
that's not going to work either
you know we'll be right back all right
sorry
[Applause]
man when i tell you that these people
need fear and endless hysteria to keep
people watching it's like has there ever
been a better example of that has there
ever been a better example of that do
you think that the supreme court is
coming for interracial marriage you know
the the founding documents which i
believe are the the best man-made
documents ever to free people to free an
imperfect people from ourselves from our
history and all of those things
which has led to 250 plus years of this
incredible evolution of freedom and more
and more equality for more people along
the way do i think that the supreme
court is suddenly going to say black
people cannot marry white people that's
what we're going to do you better watch
out clarence thomas and also
no matter how many videos you see of
these people the hypocrisy of this idea
that suddenly they want autonomy over
their lives and nobody over their bodies
and nobody's allowed to tell them what
they should do with their bodies the
same people those are the same harping
crazy women who are demanding that other
people wear masks that other people get
vaccinated that we fire other people for
their own medical decisions and much
more which had certainly much more to do
with their own personal decisions you
were forced and no one's forcing anyone
to get an abortion you were forcing
people to be injected with something
whether you knew it worked or not and if
they didn't want to get injected the way
you wanted them to get injected with
they were potentially losing their job
that's what you freaks wanted just a
couple months ago and this is why if you
have no principles if your only
principle is power that you can exercise
over people you will end up seeming like
a crazy person much like whoopi goldberg
and joy behar and sunny hostin and anna
navarro and whoever else is sitting at
that table but i do want to unpack a
little bit more related uh to the
obergfell versus hodges case which is
the the gay marriage case so blaise had
some interesting information here so
let's uh let's take a look as soon as
the united states supreme court decision
in the dobbs case overturned roe v wade
on friday many liberals and even some
libertarians began to fear that gay
marriage might be next and a concurring
opinion from justice clarence thomas may
further inflame those concerns in his
opinion siding with the majority thomas
wrote that the court should in future
cases reconsider
all of this court's substantive due
process precedents including griswold
lawrence and obergfell obergfell refers
to the landmark case obergfell versus
hodges in 2015 which legalized gay
marriage in all 50 states the chances
that the court would actually revisit
those cases those other cases are quite
slim despite the striking language in
thomas's opinion which says that the
court has a duty to correct the error
established in griswold lawrence and
obergfell all right here's the key part
here thomas does not necessarily state
that those decisions were wrongly
decided while the majority in the dobb's
opinion written by samuel alito states
unequivocally
that like the infamous decision in
plessy versus ferguson roe was also
egregiously wrong and on a collision
course with the constitution from the
day it was decided thomas does not argue
that griswold lawrence and ulbertville
were wrongly decided only perhaps
wrongly reasoned despite thomas's legal
reasoning and the fact that the court is
unlikely to revisit obergefell many on
social media media continue to assume
that gay marriage may soon go the way of
abortion okay so i really want to
address this because i see a lot of
people sending me very very mean
messages dave you're you're defending
this roe v wade decision despite the
fact that you're
begrudgingly pro-choice and they're
going to come for your marriage next so
now it's very important that people
understand
that the olberg fell case and the row
case were vastly different one was
saying oh there is this constitutional
right there is a constitutional right to
an abortion in the constitution itself
any legal any honest legal scholar knows
that that simply does not exist now what
got the supreme court in 2015 to move on
gay marriage were things that are
actually in the constitution so we have
a quote here from botanica which is a
legal website that dives in and explains
a lot of these things
writing for the majority justice anthony
kennedy asserted that the right to marry
is a fundamental right inherent with the
liberty of the person and is therefore
protected by the due process clause this
is something that's in the constitution
which prohibits the states from
depriving any person of life liberty or
property without due process of law by
virtue of the close connection between
liberty and equality the marriage right
is also guaranteed by the equal
protection clause which forbids the
states from denying to any person equal
protection of the laws kennedy then
argued at length that he reasons
that the reasons marriage is fundamental
including its connection with individual
liberty apply with equal force to
same-sex couples such considerations he
concluded compel the court that same-sex
couples may exercise the fundamental
right to marry okay so these are two
ideas concepts
laws that are in the constitution that
are in our documents that the bill of
rights is based on all of these things
due process under the law everyone
should be treated equally equal
protection under the law now is it
possible the case will get to the
supreme court i suppose that it is but
there is no evidence that uh clarence
thomas or anyone else would not would
suddenly not believe
in due process would suddenly not
believe in equal rights and all of these
things so the point is there's something
to look at in these cases that that back
up the idea that people should be able
to enter contracts equally if you were
to say oh the this set of people can't
adults can't enter a certain contract
well then you'd have to say that
everyone can't enter it
so that is
a little bit of the legal reasoning i'll
get some lawyers on here to discuss this
further or some supreme court
experts etc but i wanted to really point
to that because i think it's important
because everyone's sort of endlessly
hysterical and the other part of this is
that if you remember back in 2015
when the court decided that gay marriage
would be legal across the land 26 states
had already done
legal gay marriage through their own
judiciaries through their own
legislative process remember that do you
remember like it's hard to remember
things these days because everything's
happened so fast but you remember that
it was happening almost every week
another state was on the way to making
gay marriage legal ironically
california remember prop 8 they had
voted against gay marriage so the world
is a weird place but the point is that
in obergfell which is the gay marriage
case there are actual precedents to
point to there are things that are based
in our founding documents like due
process like equal protection under the
law that it strikes me as very uh
unlikely to reverse so i just want to
put that piece out there but now let's
shift a little bit to some of the
reaction to all of this because as
charlemagne the god pointed to earlier
the democrats really need to look in the
mirror right now it's not just that the
republicans got these supreme court
justices in and these people happen to
make their judicial decisions a little
more based in the law and the
constitution
it's that the the left itself the
democrats themselves have gone
completely bananas there virtually are
no moderate voices you know it we've
been through this before and if you want
to see that there are no moderate voices
let's look at two of the current leaders
of the democrat party and i'm going to
pick i'm not even going with aoc or
bernie or the straight up squad this
time here's stacy abrams who all she's
known as really is the loser of the
georgia gubernatorial
election who then said that elections
were illegitimate uh but uh somehow
she's someone that we're supposed to
listen to or something here's her
thoughts on abortion
do you support any limitation on
abortion or does it do you think that
women should have the right to have an
abortion all the way up to nine months
i believe an abortion is a medical
decision and i believe that that should
be a choice made between a doctor and a
woman and in consultation with her
family
so no she does not believe in any
limits on abortion this is a position
that is completely untenable that almost
nobody in real life actually believes we
all know this we've all seen pictures of
six or seven month
fetuses right okay
we've all seen it everyone knows this is
wrong everyone knows that's a life there
are babies that can be born i think the
earliest baby that's ever been born can
we maybe fact check me on this the
earliest fetus that's ever been born i
think it's around 22 weeks if i'm not
mistaken um so this is a radical a
deeply radical position that the
democrats take i'm being told it's 21
weeks is the is the least ever 21 weeks
and five days okay but this is someone
who wants you to have a medical decision
make a medical i'm not feeling very well
i don't like being pregnant i have a
little depression i should be able to
have that abortion at eight months
that's their position and by the way
it's not just her here's eric adams who
is the mayor of new york city who much
like joe biden people voted him because
they thought he was not a completely
insane democrat just a mostly insane one
mayor adams do you think there should be
any limitation on abortions uh no i do
not
none therefore totally fine
no i do not think i think women should
have a right to choose their bodies men
should not have that right to choose how
a woman should treat their bodies
really this is the same
hypocritical douchebag who was gladly
forcing people uh to inject themselves
with vaccines and everything else
suddenly they really care about people's
autonomy over their own bodies and by
the way i could show you 10
000
if we had all day an awful lot of clips
of other mainstream democrats basically
saying the whole thing so who are the
extremists right now who are really the
extremists the people who are saying hey
we shouldn't have one
law for everybody we should just send
this back to the states and you can then
decide where you want to live and if the
state is in line with your views you'll
stay there and if you really
think that abortion is the top of your
hierarchy of of importance to you in
your life and you live in alabama and
they're going to make abortion illegal
that you'll go move to california that
allows for that experiment to keep
running we'll have more on that in uh
just a second but interestingly i think
the real question is here the real
question here is does the left's
position to these progressives did their
position on unlimited abortions how is
that sort of uh how does that set up how
does that sit with our laws so we've got
an interesting quote here from apta
advice which is a website that just
basically explains a whole bunch of
stuff and here they're going to explain
what's going on uh when
the sperm meets the egg so we're going
to do some like 6th grade biology just
bear with me here for a second week
three life begins as a blastocyst so
first you have for those first few weeks
you have cells that are just multiplying
and in terms of development right now
your baby is a ball of cells called a
blastocyst the blastocyst contains dna
from you and your husband which
determines sex eye color and other
features week five their first heartbeat
so understand that at five weeks in you
are getting a heartbeat as a father to
be i can tell you very clearly that when
we heard the heartbeat this is a
powerful moment and you know that this
is a life all right let's continue uh
the development at that point not only
is your baby's heart starting to beat it
beats at twice the rate of yours week 10
now a fetus development vital organs
like the kidneys intestines brain and
liver are starting to work nails are
also visible at this age the baby's skin
is still see-through but his limbs can
move and bend your baby's fingerprints
are also developing now
we continue week 12 see your baby move
if you poke your 12-week pregnant belly
while looking at him on the ultrasound
during the parental checkup you likely
see movement week 27 the second
trimester ends
development this is the last week of
your second trimester your baby's sleep
patterns are now regular his brain is
now very active and although his lungs
aren't fully developed they can already
function on their own week 39 your baby
is now full term development your baby
is practically full term this week
however he continues to build a layer of
fat which will help him control his body
temperature
after
birth okay so the only reason that i
wanted to do that and hopefully you guys
know some of that i suspect those of you
that are parents probably are intimately
aware of all of that stuff
um
is that this simple idea this just
non-thinking idea of no it is a woman's
right to choose and she can do it at any
time with her doctor and it is not a
life in her is just
not
honest and again i say that as someone
that does believe in a pluralistic
society you have to have a few weeks 12
weeks that's three months to make some
sort of choice it's a horrific choice
that you have to decide with your spouse
or your partner and your god and
whatever your belief system is but i'm
trying to and i think most i think even
most pro-life people understand that
there's actually a lot of evidence and a
lot of polling on that that most
pro-life people do uh but here we have a
quote from live action which goes a
little bit more into some of this as
we're discussing is this a life or not
section 1 of the 14th amendment says
that a state can't deprive any person of
life liberty or property without due
process of law nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction the equal
protection of the laws clearly people do
have a constitutional right to life and
they don't have to be 18 to enjoy it now
the reason i wanted to pull that quota
particularly was because i just
mentioned due process under the law
right due process under the law which is
exactly what was argued in the case of
obergefell meaning that gay people have
every right to equality and due process
and so does this fetus at some point
acknowledging that it is life so they're
they're completely
disregarding science right these are the
people that that are we're told they
care about science you guys care about
your magical god and you wish to have us
all live in your theocracy but they're
the ones saying that a eight-month
pregnant woman
should be allowed to do whatever she
want when it is the state's very duty to
protect
life so okay the next part of this is
how they are going to use their radical
positions to govern over us i mean the
art the irony is again this decision put
more power back in individual people and
states hands but they are not really
into that uh they like when everything
is controlled from something above above
us here is vice president kamala harris
trying to figure out how they can fund
abortion no matter what and what about
the idea of financial resources
some form of voucher for travel child
care services other forms of support for
people for women seeking abortions
in states where it's not legal but they
just don't have the means to go
elsewhere i think you're asking a very
important point making a very important
point which is what are the details are
going to go into ensuring that women
have the ability to actually uh travel
without impairment and we know that on
this issue women who have access to
resources will probably be far less
impacted by this decision than women who
don't have resources so this is
something that we are looking
okay so what's interesting so it's
something we are looking at now if the
federal
government
is not in charge of abortion but then
the federal government decides to fund
people having abortions it seems like we
have a problem there right why should
your federal tax dollars go to fund
someone's el someone else's abortion as
i have said repeatedly if california and
new york and all the rich celebrities
that live there want to fund abortions
if all the democrats want to have
abortion parties and abortion
fundraisers so they can get all these
black and brown girls to come from these
scary red states and have abortions and
then maybe you get a cookie after and
then we send you back then i guess so be
it right because i am a states rights
person if individual people in certain
states want to raise money for other
people to come to their states to have
abortions that's one thing but now that
the
supreme court of the united states has
said this has nothing to do with the
federal government i don't see how the
federal government can use a dime of
anyone's money to move people
to have abortions in in states that will
keep abortion legally uh now
interestingly also let's contrast that
with that video that i showed you
earlier of joe biden in 1988 keep
government out of abortion so it seems
that joe biden of 1988 is at very
uh strange odds with joe biden of 2022
and certainly
with kamala harris of 2022
his own health and human services
secretary
xavier becerra
is also trying to figure out ways that
they can make sure that people are going
to still have abortions
how about the suggestion that's been
floated by senator elizabeth warren
about
carving out federal lands
for abortion providers is that possible
there are a number of conversations on
any number of options that can be out
there we will certainly take a close
look as we made a commitment uh some
time ago months ago as we were planning
for whatever might come from the supreme
court we will take a look at every
option to make sure a woman has access
to the care that she needs
we're not prepared to say what that
means yeah all those things have been uh
put on the table
man i mean i don't know how you can
describe this thing as anything other
than death cult
again that's within the context of you
knowing what my feelings are on abortion
are right knowing that there has to be
some wiggle room there and of course the
right to privacy and individual rights
are important and all of those things
but these people want federal lands we
will have these special federal lands
where we will pay people to come and
have seven month abortions like it
really is psychotic that is what is so
important to them it is so important
that the state should have nothing to do
with a woman's right to make medical
decisions the same freaking people the
same people that just weeks ago wanted
everybody to be injected with their
experimental vaccine right that didn't
even work that's what we are up against
right now the the it's off the charts
hypocrisy and it's it's just so in your
face it's so brazen it's so in your face
that it's actually hard to believe and
what it's really showing you is that
they actually hate representative
democracy they hate that this experiment
allows for people to live differently
they're pretending that all of us on the
scary right or whatever you want to call
it are demanding that everyone bow to
their religion and everything else when
in fact they're just giving power back
their decentralizing power these people
ironically they call themselves
pro-choice but they are the least for
choice that you can possibly imagine
here is a black lesbian wanda sykes
here's black lesbian comedian wanda
sykes on the stephen colbert
comedy program last night she has just
had it with all you people how are you
doing how you doing i'm a black gay
woman and i have a daughter so i'm not
doing so well right now
i'm a
you're a little salty i'm a little salty
right now okay yeah yeah we'll sprinkle
a little salt it really does i mean you
know it's like the
the country it's no longer a democracy
right i mean we're it's no longer
majority rule
no certainly not in the senate certainly
the problem is that middle stuff
it's those states in the middle that
that that red stuff
why they get to tell us what to do when
the majority of us live out you know new
york california and we're paying for all
this crap really i mean right
we're putting the bill
well that's that's the union it's
supposed to be a representative
democracy but it turns out to be
minority rule right now right right
there's so much stupidity there that i
actually almost have to apologize for
playing it it's so stupid first off she
is a black gay woman and she's salty
there's something funny about that um
nobody cares nobody's coming for her
you're a black gay woman and you're a
mother zippity doodah lady nobody cares
nobody's coming for you
you did your thing you're a millionaire
you're doing quite well in america it's
all good she's very upset that the
majority
uh can't rule over the minority which uh
i thought we were supposed to care about
minority rights i thought we were
supposed to look out for the other guy
but she seems to want you know if
everyone says you're supposed to do
something you're supposed to do it
the two of these wizards also have no
sense of what federalism is we've talked
quite a bit about federalism and i want
to thank phoenix today my associate
producer who brought in his copy of the
federalist papers i do have a copy of
the federalist papers here but we're
still not even fully unpacked so phoenix
brought in his copy
and let me tell you a little bit about
federalism in case i haven't made it
clear here conor threw it up on the
screen there federalism mode of
political organization that unites
separate states or other polites within
the overreaching political system in a
way that allows each to maintain its own
integrity federal systems do this by
requiring that basic policies be made
and implemented through negotiation in
some form so that all the members can
share in the making and executing of the
decisions the political principles that
animate federal systems emphasize the
primacy of bargaining and negotiated
coordination among several power centers
they stress the virtues of dispersed
power centers as a means for
safeguarding individual and local
liberties
the various political systems that call
themselves federal differ in many ways
certain characteristics and principles
however are common to all truly federal
systems so yes this is a beautiful thing
if you believe in individual choice if
you are
pro-choice pro-humans having some
capacity to make decisions for
themselves and live in places that are
more in line with their values and all
of those things then that is happening
right now but we have a black lesbian
mother who is very upset even though
nobody is coming to get her
and she's also very confused about this
majority rule thing again i thought we
supposed to care about minorities and
look out for other people this weed we
thought would be a good opportunity to
throw back to a video that i was part of
back in 2018 because i've been trying to
talk about this stuff in as many forums
as possible for quite some time and i
think as the sort of why i left the left
guy
i guess i've helped wake up a whole
bunch of people on this stuff so this is
june of 2018
i was on joe rogan's podcast explaining
federalism and the importance of local
control as opposed to top-down control
over your life i think there is some
utility for the state but the more i do
this the more i have these conversations
and i talk to handcaps and and real
libertarians and all that
i find it hard to defend the state at
almost any level at this point but i do
think that because i don't want to live
in mad max fury road just yet although
we may be heading there i still will
defend the state at some level but i
would say everything should be local we
have an incredible experiment here with
50 states if your state taxes too high
move go somewhere else if your state
doesn't have good education you can go
somewhere else if you don't like the
weather somewhere but the second we make
everything federal and this is what it's
not just the left this is what people
who are using lazy thinking that you
referred to they think we should just
have one law that we should all live
exactly the same no matter where we are
geographically no matter what our
religion or what however we set our set
of uses
that is a nightmare referring to like
it's in terms of like you want a set of
laws well because you want states rights
you you should care about estates right
so for example we live in california we
are taxed out the [ __ ] wazoo i bought
a house last year it's my first time at
41 years old that i own property in
america i made it i own property i don't
have to tell you about my property taxes
they're insane they're very high they're
they're absurdly absurdly high that's
the price you pay for living in a spot
where everybody wants to live yeah no
but that's it that's the beauty right so
like there's a trade-off there now i
could move to texas and the property
taxes would be way low and maybe because
they don't tax as much the schools
aren't as good or a series of other
things but that's the beauty of the foot
vote you can go this is an experiment
this thing in america who's against that
anyone that wants to keep giving more
power to the federal government which is
pretty much everybody these days
all right so i should pat myself on the
back for that because i've been pretty
consistent in what i've been talking
about for years
as my guys were looking for that clip we
found this which was pretty kind of
funny in that i nailed exactly what was
going to happen to joe rogan
you can move your family your value
whatever you bring to your community in
your life i mean think about it right
now if california just kept taxing
higher and higher and kept screwing up a
lot of there's a ton that's going wrong
in the state eventually joe rogan might
be like you know i just built this
freaking kick-ass new studio here i'm
now paying
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
taxes and all this stuff you might want
to try it somewhere else where they're
going to tax you less but that's the
beauty of the thing you don't have to
leave the country so the federal
government should pretty much
do nothing it should make sure we're not
warring with each other that the states
aren't warring
that's about and then protect the
borders
beyond that it doesn't have to do a lot
leave it to the state
dave rubin guy who's consistently said
what he thinks and it kind of does make
sense and as long as we're doing a trip
down memory lane this is my retirement
show i think a year before that in
february 2017 i did that very famous it
has now been seen probably over 50
million times across platforms i did
that why i left the left video that is
the thing that kind of poured rocket
fuel on everything else i was doing at
the time and i explained my rationale
for not wanting the government to
intervene on anyone's values
i'm a married gay man so you might think
that i appreciate the government forcing
a christian baker or photographer or
florist to act against their religion in
order to cater photograph or decorate my
wedding but you'd be wrong a government
that can force christians to violate
their conscience can force me to violate
mine if a baker won't bake you a cake
find another baker don't demand that the
state tell him what to do with his
private business
i'm pro-choice but a government that can
force a group of catholic nuns literally
called the little sisters of the poor to
violate their faith and pay for
abortion-inducing birth control can
force anyone to do anything
that's not progressive that's regressive
last from the past and i used to say
regressive left all the time some of you
remember that uh but okay so there's
some calm rational thought and i really
am doing that not to pat myself on the
back but just to show you that there's
many people and many books out there and
many papers that have been written of
people defending what freedom is people
defending
individual rights and your ability to
make decisions over your own life and
all of those things but what do the
people that want to control you have to
do in the face of calm rational thought
and some of the stuff that i laid out in
those videos right there what they have
to do is really scare you and when the
way the way they can scare you best is
telling you that uh people are gonna die
here's hillary clinton
justice thomas has sort of floated that
out there about contraceptive rights and
contraception and about same-sex
marriages but other justices have pushed
back to say no he's really sort of on
his own with that well he believes that
well he may be on his own but he's
signaling
as he often did you know people i went
to law school with him he's been
a person of grievance for as long as
i've known him resentment grievance
anger
and he has signaled uh in the past
two lower courts two state legislatures
to find cases pass laws
get them up i may not win the first the
second or the third time but we're going
to keep at it so you're saying people
pay attention to yes the people he is
speaking to which are the you know
right-wing very conservative judges and
justices and state legislatures
and the thing that uh is well there's so
many things about it that are deeply
distressing
but women are going to die gail women
will die
someone should tell hillary what happens
when someone has a seven month abortion
pretty sure someone dies and that
includes what would eventually become a
woman it's a girl it's a female
and they die in abortions
but i guess she doesn't really care
about that i also think it's rather
extraordinary what she says there she
says that clarence thomas basically is
filled with resentment
grievance and anger
isn't that exactly what drives the
democrat movement of today isn't that
exactly what wokism and progressivism is
all about that minorities are supposed
to be resentful of an america that's
systemically racist that they're
supposed to have grievance against all
of the mean laws and the patriarchy and
all of the things and they damn well
should be angry which is why they burn
buildings down in the name of uh
tolerance
so it's a very bizarre position that
hillary clinton is holding hillary
clinton by the way she is married to a
rapist and also in the 90s you may
remember she was the one that concocted
a vast right-wing conspiracy that turned
out to be uh totally true that's hillary
clinton right there also she uh said
that the election in 2016 was
illegitimate so
oh by the way if i die in the next
couple days i did not commit suicide i'm
just putting that out there right now
because if you say anything bad about
hillary they take you out and i just
want to be clear i have never been
happier or more fulfilled in life i feel
like i'm doing good work i'm about to
have kids i love life i love what i'm
doing and uh okay there we go uh so what
do we do about all this well i found
this video of a resentful
grievance-filled angry guy and i thought
that he maybe made a good point on it
you can be in the middle of a hurricane
or you can be on a calm day north is
still north
you could be in a thunderstorm north is
still north
people can yell at you north is still
north
it doesn't change fundamental things
and in this business right is still
right
even if you stand by yourself
grievance
anger man is he just filled with it
talking about truth and doing the right
thing boy guy is just overflowing with
hostility it just never ends uh dare i
quote myself sort of quoting something
else from doper in this country talking
about individualism allow me right here
uh the term individualism itself was
first coined by alexis de tocqueville's
democracy in america tocqueville forever
in his invest forever the invested
far-off onlooker understood american
democracy what he called the equality of
conditions not merely as a way to govern
but as a way to live
individualism was a lifestyle not rooted
in selfishness but self-reliance
empowering the individual to be
dependent on no man nor entity other
than himself if you have not read it
that was from don't burn this country
which hopefully you've read but here is
alexis de tocqueville's democracy in
america and that spirit that spirit is
what they're coming for right now when
they tell you no no no we must have one
law to rule everybody you need us if you
don't give us power you will be afraid
no no the purpose of that spirit of
america is to be spirited to be
independent to be self-reliant and not
reliant on that machine so what do you
do about that as we continue our trip
down memory lane well you freaking stand
up you stand up to them and you knock
down the lies and you be brave in a time
when we have a
bravery deficit so what can you do
believe it or not the solution is not
that hard step one think for yourself
step two say it out loud just because a
former bartender says the world is going
to end in 12 years because of climate
change doesn't mean it's true
doomsdayers have been saying the same
thing for decades and we're still here
just because a filmmaker says we should
model our health care system on cuba's
doesn't mean it's a good idea would you
rather have heart surgery in houston or
in havana
and just because a career politician is
a millionaire with three houses who
rails against the rich doesn't make him
a hypocrite oh wait in that case it
actually does the point is perhaps your
most important job as a human being is
to stand up for the things you believe
in
don't take the path of least resistance
be better than those who would silence
you de-platform you and mob you
how
just stop being afraid
how about that guy kind of makes some
sense doesn't he uh all right guys we've
got a great cold clothes for you um
before though i do want to reference so
that was obviously from my i believe
that was my third prageru video uh which
was the bravery deficit and if you want
to see my most recent prageru video
which is all about
democracy in america and some of the
ideas i've shared here you can go to
prageru's either their website or their
youtube page three ways to fix america
is the title for the video all right
let's jump to some comments at
reubenreport.locals.com and i think
we've got some from the rumble community
as well mad for cars says of course
companies want to pay for abortions
cheaper than having someone out on
maternity leave companies spend millions
when they hire women then they become
pregnant you know it's an interesting
point and i don't think it's a very
cynical point actually someone might
read that and say oh you're such a cynic
but no i think that's actually quite
true if a company hires somebody to do a
job and they go oh boy we're gonna have
to let them go for a couple months
because of maternity leave but we can
just ship them to federal lands out in
oklahoma to an indian reservation or
something and they'll have an abortion
uh well gosh darn it i guess we'll do
that and we'll save some money
so the whole corporate part of this is
all such nonsense uh that all of these
companies want to fund these abortions
it's like the corporate thing with the
with pride month and all that they don't
give a crap this is all about control
over people
ab says my friend had her baby at 21
weeks and there was a lot of medical
intervention of course but she is happy
she is a happy healthy grown 28 year old
woman now amen to that that is
absolutely incredible i mean 21
weeks so again this is where we can have
some of that discussion okay should we
have 12 weeks
where hopefully people can figure out
alternatives but should be able to make
their own decisions and are there are
there the fringe cases where the the
child will never be able to live a fully
actualized life because of whatever
their condition uh developmental
condition is or should we have certain
carve-outs for the health of the woman
of in my estimation of course we should
have all of those things in most
pro-life peoples
in most pro-life people's positions and
thoughts
i think you have some carve-outs on some
of those things but again even if there
is one state that is the most extreme on
this you'd still be able to leave the
state and do what you had to do and this
is that constant tension that will exist
between private and personal decisions
and what the government should or should
not do genie says i'm baffled that they
call a fetus my body it's not as if
their spleen could grow up to be their
best friend and closest loved one well i
have a feeling a lot of people uh of
these people don't have that many
friends and maybe their spleen is their
best friend but you see what i'm talking
about whether it's whoopi
or joy behar or hillary or bersera
or kamala i mean this this sort of death
cult like anyone should have an abortion
you people are all evil you want to
control us they they don't realize that
they've spent the last two years trying
to control us and i think the best thing
that we can do
is go back
to some of these documents how about the
federalist papers look at what's in
actually in the constitution understand
what your
god guaranteed rights are your god-given
rights are and that the government
didn't give them to you there's
something before that
and that we find these truths to be
self-evident so we don't endlessly
debate every little thing they find no
truths to be self-evident boys or girls
two plus two is five we don't have time
for that anymore we have a country to
save are you with me
uh reminder july 14th in miami do we
have the image one more time with the
image we got the image there we go look
at those classes uh daverubin.com events
and christina pusha who is ron desantis
press secretary right here in the great
state of florida will be joining me part
one of my interview with christy gnome
the governor of south dakota is up right
now really enjoyed talking to her and
she did a really bang-up job defending
uh her citizens in south carolina south
dakota from the lockdowns and the rest
of the nonsense and finally i do think
you'll enjoy
this cold close
have a nice day
my choice
my choice
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i will not
be
stopped join with us right now